[Music]
we are gonna make boy band history
tonight bro you're making baby Branch
nervous I feel like I'm gonna bath and
pass out and do your pants all at once
how do you know
[Music]
[Applause]
you suck my exquisitely chiseled rock
hard abs and I quit French we're out of
sync we've gone from Boys to Men and now
there's only one direction for us to go
the back streets bye see you later
Ranch what oh hey are you all right
you're smiling and crying at the same
time it kind of looks like it's hurting
your face it does hurt my face
[Music]
I'm John Doherty Branch's brother
former brother
[Music]
a brother is a friend who can never
leave you it's the strongest bond in the
world I would kill to have a sibling to
sing with check out your old outfits
puffy jackets nail necklaces
did you have frosted tips look at you
you were so cute I love it it was an ERA
tragic friends my brother is being held
captive in a diamond prison there's only
one thing that's powerful enough to
shatter Diamond the perfect family
Harmony should we be letting a baby
drive I have procured my learner's
permit with a Dolce McMahon face the
better question is are you a narc
we're here looking for our brother
[Music]
oh my gosh
my name is
via it is so fantastic amazing to see
other trolls did you just braid my hair
you're welcome it looks so good I love
it is your dad King Pepe uh yeah poppy
I'm your sister my what whoa hey man am
I the only one without a long lost
sibling this is your second chance with
your brother's branch
maybe a smaller diaper this diaper was
any smaller I could
I could take I know you think it's risky
and maybe it is but it'll be worth it
anyways always worth it
[Music]
if you got it looks like your Band-Aids
aren't behind you
just let me take it to a better place
[Laughter]
[Music]